Since we are still in the shopping period.
And, uh, some turnover.
I thought it might be good if I
spent the first three or four minutes
recapitulating from meeting one.
Uh,
and then a little more on meeting too.
And then we'll feather
that into today's topic,
which is,
uh,
the great work of economics and the great
and most greatest and most thoughtful,
a normative tracked about
markets and capitalism.
I will, uh, I'll begin,
as I said with the recapitulation,
then we'll talk about some basic
components of Smith's argument.
Uh,
then we'll,
I'll turn the slides off for a while
and we will talk informally and I'll
include a Jim Alexander in
the conversation about the
way Smith and Smith Ism,
uh,
plays out in today's world and how
it contradicts in many respects.
Uh, what the great man
actually said and meant to say.
Okay. Before meeting to meeting one
meeting, one really just said this,
that the enormous surge in human wealth
over the past 250 years has a great deal
to do with capital,
with the intelligent use of
accumulated wealth in fresh production.
That capitalism is a subset of
the ways you can use capital.
Even socialism uses capital, uh, even,
uh, fascism uses capital, uh,
even squirrels and spiders in
some sense or another use capital.
But capitalism is the subspecies where
wealth accumulated is deployed so as to
create new wealth and to do so
in a competitive environment.
And that second,
second piece,
capitalism was not invented by
some smart guy like Adam Smith,
but rather evolved organically by
trial and error by experimentation,
uh, by failure. Uh, indeed,
if you look at a market society,
one of its great features is that
it's history is littered with failure
and learning to uh,
two analyze past success and past
failure becomes a key part of it.
That's the one last point.
And the is a mitten.
Capitalism is not something which
originally was invented by its friends,
but rather by its enemies.
Uh,
it was Marxism and other,
uh,
left wing movements in the
early and middle 19th century
when the writer Rick of
capitalism appeared indeed the
word had no appearance, whatever.
Uh,
before that era
in meeting two,
we looked at the kinetic kinetic
structure of the world economy,
uh, with this Hans Rolling, uh,
diagram animated I,
it's still today,
but animated so that life expectancy
and a income per capita could be seen
moving dynamically across years. And, uh,
we discovered that the typical story
is a surge north in the diagram
representing increased life expectancy
with slow progress in income per capita,
and then a surge around the,
around the horn, so to speak,
into the area,
upper right of long lives
and relative affluence.
And I asserted,
and many of you agreed that there's
something unambiguously good about that
change,
that the world is a better place
because that change happened.
Now, I didn't in the, in
the, in the lecture, uh,
lay any great stress on the caveats
that people might attached to that.
One of them is that it was accomplished
in considerable measure through capital
intensive, uh, industry, uh,
and Hiogly in capital intensive
forms of transportation.
And that these were,
uh,
first of all disruptive of
the natural environment.
There could be no doubt,
whatever,
that the revolution in the world economy,
uh, left the planet more
fragile than it found it. Uh,
indeed,
uh,
poverty is a marvelous
environmental policy
because where there is no demand,
there is very little disruption.
Now
we also looked at the world
demographic transition,
the world demographic transition
representing changes in rates of birth and
death,
death here in purple and birth in
green and the old Malthusian world,
uh,
which still exists on parts of the globe
but hasn't existed in the Western world
for a couple of hundred years was
characterized by very high birth rates and
very high death rates.
So you have essentially static total
population and very few people live to be
old.
Yeah.
Then you have the change in the death
rate occasion by infrastructure,
most of all related to clean water.
And when the death rate falls,
the birth rate doesn't track with it.
The birth rate lags in its change.
So there is a period,
phase two here when deaths are falling
sharply and births are statically high
and in that period you get any normous
surge you get indeed population growth.
At an increasing rate.
So you get,
you get the spike,
which brought world population to its
present level is occasion largely by phase
two.
Phase three
is the period during which the birth
rate adjusts to the death rate and you
still get growing population.
But now at a diminishing rate
and at stage four,
there's an equilibrium between births
and deaths and both have lower rate.
So population is again,
static,
uh,
and lives are much longer.
Okay.
Underneath that,
underneath that process,
and this I merely hinted
at in meeting two,
is a surge in the supply of labor,
which occurs in stages two and three and
create a buyer's market for employers.
And by creating a buyer
buyer's market for employers,
it drives down wages.
Real wages are really quite low.
Uh, during Stage two and stage
three in the history of a country,
uh,
and capitol,
which is only in part
related to demography,
it has an independent life of its own,
but capitol begins to appreciate and be
agglomerated in large quantities only
late in this history.
So the places where you get huge buildup
of capital are typically places which
beginning or well into stage four.
And if you want to be precise about it,
there is a stage five,
which is where the birth rate has
actually fallen below the death rate.
So that as with Japan, Italy,
Russia, and much of eastern Europe,
you have falling total population.
Now there's another aspect of this
that we'll pick up a month from now,
which has to do with the age
profile of the existing population.
And you can ask yourself what percentage
of all the people in a country are of
working age.
And you can figure from that
a so called dependency ratio.
How many people too old to work and too
young to work have to be supported by
those who can work,
who are of working age.
And that ratio turns out to be a
big determinant of economic growth.
Where as with China,
a China today,
Ireland in the very recent past,
you have a demographic sweet spot where
there are relatively few old and young
people and almost everybody is
in the working years. Uh, it's,
that's a,
that's a really a low resistance profile.
And then at the other side,
the Japanese were the number of elderly
people who need to be supported,
uh, is out of proportion to the
size of the actual workforce
beneath beneath this,
uh,
these curves related to capital and labor,
are, uh, just a few other
things you want to think about.
One is that you get much higher incomes
in phase four than in earlier phases.
And it's partly because of
capital concentration, uh,
but it's also because human capital,
human capital in the form of
trained ability educated people,
uh,
because it becomes much easier to
build a massive educational apparatus,
a formula apparatus,
and also an applied apparatus
in the workforce where in
40 years of working in a
given trade,
people get really good at it.
So that,
uh,
that's another way in which the later
stages of the world demographic transition
are profitable, quite
literally to a country. Uh,
any quality tends to be highest in the
emerging markets because typically what
you get is a mass of very poor
people and a relatively small elite,
which has found its way
into capitalist development.
Uh, labor, abundant capital scarce,
we talked about that.
Uh,
insourcing and outsourcing.
This is a very obvious point.
Stage four countries outsource tasks
to stage two and three countries,
uh, because labor is much cheaper. I,
and um,
and the,
the adverse of that is
insourcing at the other end.
And the main movement in Stage two and
three countries actually has two parts.
One is from countryside to city because
the opportunities of capital intensive
enterprise are concentrated in cities
and from an out of stage two and three
countries into stage four countries.
And this is a classic pattern
which is highly visible today with,
uh,
the borders of the United States and
Europe being a crowded and not entirely
controlled.
And it was the same story a hundred years
ago when southern and Eastern Europe,
we're in a stage three in the United
States was approaching stage four.
And immigration, uh, was enormous.
My own family on my father's side were
immigrants in the early 20th century.
Okay.
So Smith's invisible hand.
MMM.
The question is,
if it's invisible,
how can we know it's there?
And there are various,
there are several good New Yorker
cartoons about that problem.
One shows a group of well dressed people
gathered in a farm field near Darien,
Connecticut looking out with
binoculars to fly the invisible hand,
which has been reported to
have appeared there. Uh,
another is a store with a sign across the
front store closing and then a caption
under the store closing sign,
bitch slapped by the invisible hand.
Um,
the,
the
condition under which
the invisible hand works,
uh, is actually, there are several things
that have to be there for it to happen.
And let's just kind of
kind of inventory those.
First is you have to have an open market,
has to be a market where people can come
in and begin to produce our arrive in,
begin to consume. If it
is regulated, for example,
by tariffs,
uh,
or buy a mafia,
then that is the visible hand and the
invisible hand is blocked from its work.
Okay.
There needs to be no seller
big enough to drive down to,
to control prices by say,
withholding product.
There needs third to be no buyer.
Uh,
I've left out a step,
no sour and no buyer
able to control prices.
And what would make that,
what kind of distribution of production
and buying would be required to do that?
Somebody, somebody near a mic.
Got a mic. Where's the mic guys?
Okay.
A
okay.
Those are the things you don't want if
you want the invisible hand to work,
right.
What you want is somebody else.
Yes.
Okay.
And perfect competition occurs when one
k but that's circular.
Okay?
So we need to put one
step in between there.
Well,
that's,
that's work at this what I showed a
picture when I started this of a wheat
field.
Uh,
and I didn't show a picture
of a car factory or Microsoft.
Uh,
the key fact is that you have a fine
grain division of production and
consumption. So there are thousands
and thousands of producers,
thousands and thousands of consumers.
No one of them big enough
to gain the market,
right? If you're a, if you're making,
if you're producing wheat or rice
and you say the world prices too low,
I'm going to drive it up by withholding
this year's crop from my hundred acres.
That's like hit my hand because
you have no market power.
Uh, no producer holds a pivotal,
pivotal private technology.
Uh,
and
it's pretty obvious what's meant by that.
A patented technology or a trade secret,
which allows one producer to differentiate
him or herself from other producers
and dominate the market.
Are there,
is there the buyers and
perfect information,
more or less truthful information
across the whole market?
Yeah,
and government to enforce
property and contract.
So with all those conditions in place,
what,
what Smith's says about the
invisible hand is more or less true.
See if I can find the quote.
And he talks about producers who are in
this and many other cases led by by an
invisible hand to promote the end,
which,
which they have no part of an
intention by pursuing his own interest.
He frequently promotes that of
society more effectually then when he,
when he really intends to promote it.
I have never known much good to come
from people trading in the name of the
public good.
So the,
on both the producer
and the consumer side,
there is a peculiar power vacuum.
There is no one who can be said to have
set the price of the good or determined
it's quality.
It is decided collectively.
And the Smithian idea there is actually
the idea of general equilibrium in a
market economy. The next phase of
economic theory, neoclassical economics,
uh, formalizes this idea and
makes it mathematically precise.
And we will look at it in a little while,
but here,
uh,
it's important first just to get the
context in which Smith writes about the
invisible hand in the wealth of nations.
Anybody able to provide us with the
exact point he's trying to prove?
Is there a hand somewhere?
You're trying to set this guy up?
I know that,
but was there wave at please?
Okay,
yes. You need the mic.
Where's it? Come on guys.
We gotta manage the mic better here,
whereas it
just,
it doesn't work without them.
Would one of you guys just kind of
stay standing and get it to people?
Wow.
It shouldn't impose tariffs.
Okay.
He's arguing against tariffs and
for free trade. Right. And why,
why do, why is that an
argumentative point for him?
Why are they're terrorists?
Uh,
because the nation's thought that they
were protecting their economies by
enforcing. Okay. And who were
they helped to reach that?
Who helped the nations
to reach that conclusion?
Other economists? Well, yeah, sure. No,
I'm fishing for something
a little different. Let's
pass the Mike over to the,
is it the violin question?
The Viola question? Okay.
My wife is a violist. Great. Um,
I guess the predominant economic
philosophy at the time when Adam Smith was
writing was mercantilism mercantilism
market to listen, which is, you know, uh,
accumulate as much gold as possible,
become the richest, you know,
individual through that
regard. Which means, you know,
not really importing much and really
focusing on supporting domestic and,
okay, go ahead. So that's excellent.
So Smith was anti mercantilist,
he was a free trader and the people who
had a concrete interest in tariff and
tariff tariff in possession,
who would,
who would have a strong self interest
in that? Let's get the mic over here.
I think one of UTS really needs to just
stand up and MC they thing a domestic
merchants and manufacturers, well
certainly manufacturers, right?
Domestic manufacturers who are in some
way or another not competitive with
imports. Right? And, and Smith
has this wonderful passage,
I think it's near this,
where he talks about how you could,
you could in Scotland produce good one,
right? You'd have to have hot houses and
many other special and very expensive
accouterments.
But for about 30 times the price
of the production price of France,
Spain or Italy,
you could produce Scottish wine.
But it would be a foolish betrayal of
the public interest to put up a tariff so
that you could then sell that wine worth
$2 for $200 and that's the center of
his argument, right? And he begins,
he begins at the micro level with the
butcher, the baker and the brewer.
Uh, which is a metaphor that
rings true for most of us, right?
Why are the,
why is the produce fresh in the little
market on Orange Street in new haven?
And the main reason is because there
are two little markets in new haven.
If we're just one 36 hour old,
lettuce would be marketable,
but with two,
one of whom drives to New York every
morning at three that just doesn't work.
So that Smith talks about the self
interest axiom as the driver for promoting
the common good.
Now I'm going to invite Jim Alexander
come on up and we'll just stand
and let's actually sit and talk.
Some of you who have been very
adept introduced to Jim Alexander,
uh, and for others, I'll introduce him.
Now a Jim is a good friend and,
uh, was, had a 20 year
career in investment banking.
And after that,
a stint as chief financial officer
of Enron global power and pipeline,
uh, which was indeed one of
the famous partnerships, uh,
in the Enron meltdown.
He was a straight shooter,
uh,
as the best book on the Enron meltdown,
calls him the fly in the
ointment, uh, and went off,
uh,
to cofound spinnaker exploration,
which later became a public company.
Um,
and Jim is going to be part of
this course from time to time.
And I thought maybe to bring the,
uh,
the discussion down from the clouds here,
I would ask Jim,
is the ghost of Adam Smith
alive in the boardroom,
uh, in corporate America? Well,
the
self image of Adam Smith is alive.
The ideology that would be
espoused is that of Adam Smith.
The substance is not there.
Uh,
I believe that most of the people
would pass the polygraph test that they
believe it's there. Okay, that's good.
Now, let's, here's an interesting,
interesting exercise. There are
about a dozen Mbas in the group here.
Uh,
every MBA,
every MBA period, uh, has
learned the porter forces.
And what are the porter forces?
The porter forces are the rules of thumb
you need to make above average profits
with a firm. Okay? And one
of them is, you know, what,
too much competition, direct competition,
direct competition. He roads profits.
You want high barriers to entry.
Uh,
you don't want powerful buyers who
can drive down your price through
negotiating. For example,
tire companies, space,
very powerful buyers in
automobile manufacturers.
You want to avoid situations like that.
You also want to be able to control your
supplier so they can't see you making
profits and then demand their share.
Now just think for a second,
how do the porter forces
aligned with the conditions, uh,
that I sketch five minutes ago for
the operation, the invisible hand
in the back,
you gotta be really loud because
they are essentially the exact opposite.
The name in business speak for operating
under the control of the invisible hand
is commodity hell
okay.
Right?
Commodity hell being that you're producing
something which thousands of other
people can produce and they can produce
it as cheaply. And as well as you can.
And so the available pricing strategies
to you are not of them involve high
profits. Right? So one of the,
one of the fundamental axiom,
so business management,
and I'm not making a moral condemnation,
I'm just making an observation
that there is a strong tension here
that the,
the,
the pursuit of actual act,
the actual submission to the invisible
hand is contrary to the very basis of
corporate strategy. Uh, Jim,
we'll talk, I would talk a little
from your experience about,
uh,
the
intelligent use of the porter
forces by management strategist
or intelligent,
well, the latter, but,
but basically a no one ever wants to
get into a Adam Smith's type of market.
And if you, if you're in it, you get out
of it. I mean, because there's a, it,
it's ruinous. Uh, and uh,
the only way you can, uh, affect,
affect change in,
in that that type of market is to do
what Adam Smith suggested in that is make
some sort of national security argument.
Why in fact,
wow,
Smith's views are very
well and fine in general.
You need in the country more of especially
needs to have a defense against a
foreign imports or ruinous competition.
I think the sugar producers were able
to pull that off pretty neatly and make
them make a national security
argument for, for sugar quotas. Uh,
but that's uh, but you never tolerate a
and Adam Smith a level of competition.
Okay.
And if you look at,
I ordered a thank you for smoking Chris
Christopher Buckley's book as an option
for this course, but I'm told
all of you have seen the movie,
which I haven't. It's
a movie any good. Okay.
So you should all look at the movie.
And the book is all about the way,
uh,
corporations, including those which
make, in this case, cigarettes,
booze and a firearms,
but mostly cigarettes,
uh,
have elaborate representation in
Washington and promote their own interests
through the law.
It's not a big surprise,
but the tension between the idealized
theory of the market and that practice is
a very strong one.
And incidentally,
Smith was very critical of the
corporations which existed in his time,
uh,
knots.
And he was critical of them for partly
the reason we just articulated that they
can control pricing,
uh,
and impose their product, uh, by,
by that method.
Uh,
but more Smith thought that the
people running the corporations,
which existed at that time
were thoroughly and competent.
And that's of course because the Yale
School of management had not yet been
founded.
But it in actual fact there is a
fundamental problem about corporations and
their management called the
principal agency problem.
And the gist of that,
of that problem is that managers
left to their own devices,
will tend to take a company where in
a direction which is best for them
individually and not necessarily
for the broad body of shareholders.
And so the control over that
tendency gets to be one of the major,
uh, dramatic themes in business life. Jim,
you've been near some management which
had a rent seeking tendencies.
Well, let me come back to something
else and that is that, uh,
at least one of the
sections Smith has, uh, uh,
revolves around, uh, the butcher,
the brewer and the baker. Yup.
And what's much more reliable to
rely on their self interest than
their benevolence, which is true.
But there's, there's, there's a, uh,
I think there's an embedded assumption
which he doesn't go into and that is,
he cites examples of what her,
at least at the time were,
were single proprietor,
a sort of businesses marketing a
product which was directly consumed by
individuals who knew the proprietors well
and understood what good meat was from
Meta wasn't good. Right.
Uh, and, uh, that,
that also is increasingly irrelevant,
uh,
since his time because one of the most
important things I thought in one of your
slides was that there'd
be perfect information.
And on top of that and embedded assumption
there is that there has to be perfect
information. Perfectly understood.
Absolutely. And, and in fact,
one of the, um, you know, I
haven't come from finance,
it's sort of the highest form
of art is to have information,
which in retrospect can
be defended as reliable,
but prospectively ha as
virtually meaningless. Uh,
so one of the ways you can, uh, that,
that it really becomes
very important in practice,
right yet about the Smithian ideals is
to make sure that you have colorable
information colorable of
voluntary transactions.
But in fact they're, uh, they
are practically speaking,
not voluntary and practically speaking,
not informed.
You can, on top of that, you start
having principal agent issues.
Let's take the,
the butcher for example,
one butcher in a little village
deals with people he knows.
So there's social
constraints and there's also,
it's fairly easy if it's one
butcher to trace the s uh, any,
any illnesses that result it match.
And,
and he is,
has a relatively non marketable asset,
which is his interest in his private.
What's your shop? Very hard to sell.
So he must count on long
term profit maximization, uh,
to not short term but long term.
Now let's imagine you had a,
I don't think I would be
processors as public at this point,
but let's imagine that
you had a, uh, a, uh, uh,
a butcher business,
which was owned by the public,
controlled by a small group of
managers. And furthermore, uh,
let's assume,
and it's actually a pretty good
assumption that you had a group of semi
knowledgeable and mutual fund managers
who rewarded people with huge gains in
their share value if they were able to
reliably to hit their quarterly earnings
estimates and punish them.
Of course,
if anything went wrong
under those circumstances,
assuming that the investing public really
didn't understand the dynamics of the
business and assuming that you could
make satisfactory short term goals,
maybe making maybe a hundred times the
average income of the typical worker
every couple of weeks,
um,
then you would be incentivized
unless you are very risk averse to,
for example,
being able to buy tainted meat and then
be able to make some extra pennies,
beat your numbers,
get a big up a upgrade in your stock.
If you have a lot of options, you have
a very highly leveraged well situation,
then make enough money in the
short term where you could live,
you could maybe buy a small country or
liberal it with gravy for the rest of
your life on a basis, which was
sufficiently confusing that you,
you'd be unlikely to be prosecuted.
Right?
That's my experience as to how it works.
I realize that it's,
that it's a small sliver and
it is oriented toward finance,
which is the worst part
of American business.
But that's in fact how I've seen it work.
Uh, no theories. It's just how it works.
Uh,
you know,
so people believe and yet the same
people who would do this would spout and
believe every bit of it. The same type
of Smithy and idealism you see here,
invisible hand. Well, my experience,
the invisible hand typically is picking
someone's pocket, not creating value.
And in fact, you know, I'll
get off of this, but the last
I remember,
uh,
talking to the senior Republican staff
are at the House Energy and Commerce
Committee and making the answer is by
the way, I believe you are a Republican.
Used to be. It used to be, um,
this is how I used to be.
I remember talking to the lead Republican
staffer or the House Energy and
Commerce Committee and saying at one
point that capitalism justifies itself by
creating real, not elusory
value to which he replied, well,
you're nothing but a communist.
And that in fact is,
is the problem is,
is under Smithian
assumptions about a longterm,
uh, honesty, longterm interest in real
value creation. It works perfectly.
It just that when those,
when those assumptions start to erode,
it turns into a nightmare.
Terrific.
Uh, Giorgio's now I'm going to call on
you in a moment for a one sentence read.
Uh,
here's the proposition that we
now want to look at a Smith.
Here's a, here's a, an appearance but
not real paradox. Adam spent says,
self interest is the main motive
for what people actually do.
And yet he led a life which didn't begin
to maximize his own material interest.
He lived modestly. He
worked diligently. He,
uh, never, uh, became a wealthy man.
So if he believed it for mankind,
how come you didn't practice
it for himself? Well,
Richard Material.
Okay,
fair enough.
That's a good point.
The other side of it is that wealth
of nations was Smith second main book.
And it wasn't the book which made
him famous in his own lifetime.
The theory of moral sentiments is the
book which made him famous in his own
lifetime.
And George Ross,
will you read us please
in good strong voice,
the first sentence of Smith's first book.
Thanks very much Lesley.
How self soever man may be supposed there.
Evidently some principles in his nature
which interests him in the fortune of
the others and re render their
happiness necessary to him,
though he derives nothing from me
except the pleasure of seeing it. Okay.
And now read it one more time.
How Selfoss so clever man may be supposed,
they're evident,
evidently some principles in his nature,
which interest him and the fortune
of others and render their happiness
necessary to him,
though he derives nothing from it
except the pleasure of seeing it.
Okay.
So Smith actually believed
that we were a complicated mix,
and I think he's right.
And he believed that there is a prosocial
element in almost every human being.
There is a,
an innate sympathy for others,
which almost everyone has.
And at the same time,
a tendency to feather one's own nest.
Now,
I don't know anyone who is
just one of those two things.
I don't know anyone
who is a pure Iga test.
You do?
My goodness.
Okay.
Not even generous to his aged mother or,
okay. Well there may be some.
Yeah, there may be some,
but there aren't a hell of a lot. And uh,
Smith, this is characteristic of Smith.
Smith is not a dogmatist.
Smith is a careful observer
who draws as much from,
uh, from the evidence
as is there. Now, uh,
this is a map which links
Smith forward to the next,
a historical period, namely, uh,
the period when a world trade got serious
and the period which we will discuss
in Monday's class when Marx and Engels
we're writing the communist manifesto,
the picture on the board
is the world railroad grid.
And if you think about Smith's story,
about how wealth depends on the division
of labor works only where you have a
large market
and he makes that point at length.
And in the period which begins in the
middle 18 hundreds really begins about
1840.
In that period,
really large markets became accessible
to everyone located in the dance part of
the world, railway, railway grip.
And toward the end of the semester we'll
be dealing with the problem of economic
development in places like these.
And if you look at the way
the railroads develop there,
they all developed to reach,
uh,
ocean ports for the export of products,
products to world markets.
And the density of connection required
for the internal development of large
markets was by and large mission.
Okay.
No,
I think I'll just finish with,
uh,
Adam Smith's story about the pin making
and what happened to the pin making
story.
Smith,
I actually didn't have your read this
because it's something everybody,
I think everybody learns
this one in high school,
the division of Labor for Smith is
illustrated by a group of artisans making
pins and one person gets really good
at drawing the wire out straight.
Another person at hammering
ahead onto the wire,
another person at making the point sharp,
another person at polishing the shaft.
And by division of Labor and
development of expertise,
they can produce more pins of higher
quality than a single artists and doing
each of those operations by
himself could possibly have done.
And that's,
it's a good illustration.
And if you think about all the professions
and occupations in an economy that
kind of profiting from that way of
profiting from specialized expertise is
foundational. It's a market societies
foundational to their wealth.
Now the actual fate of the pin machine is,
uh,
interesting and personal to my family.
Uh,
it turns out that in 1831,
a New York physician named John Ireland,
how h o w e,
uh,
began to tinker with the idea of making
a machine where wire went in one end and
polished pins came out the
other in their thousands.
And by 1851,
he what was called the how pin machine.
There's a room in the
Smithsonian to this day where a,
how pin machine shits and a movie of
its operation goes on behind it. Well,
John Ireland,
how I won't brag again in this semester
was my five over great grandfather and
the family began pissing away the money
right away and completed the task just
in time for my birth.
So
the slides include a formalization of
equilibrium theory with an Edgeworth box
and indifference curves and all that.
Uh,
but I don't think we have
time to do them here.
And I urge you to review them
before the midterm, uh, on the,
on classes be too. So on Wednesday
we are Monday rather, we'll do,
uh,
the communist manifesto.
And on Wednesday we'll do Hayak
and the constitution of liberty.
So we'll see two ends of the ideological
perspective in a single week.
And after that, we will spend four
straight weeks on business cases.